12 dicembre aeroporto malpensa 8.45 del
mattino
stiamo per imbarcare partenza per mosca
siamo curiosissimi di uscire da questa
scala qui e sentire il freddo di mosca
io pensavo peggio dai
qui la nostra stanza guardate che
meraviglia e sulla scrivania
ci sono due colbacchi e questi due
portachiavi con le matrioske e quella è
la view non si vede bene perché c'è il
riflesso ma lì c'è la piazza rossa quindi
siamo proprio in centro centro
allora prima sera ho deciso di tagliare
i capelli
mi piace questo nuovo look
scherzo é una parrucca però mi piacciono
stasera cena in un ristorante italiano che
si chiama sartoria lamberti devo dire
che per adesso mi stai piacendo nonostante non sia un amante dei ristoranti italiani all'estero
oggi primo giorno di tour di
mosca io sono entrata nel personaggio
salvo pure
modalità natalizia attivata vi presento
la nostra guida per oggi la signora
natalia e buffissima parla ovviamente
inglese con l'accento russo
oggi pranzo qui siamo al white rabbit
che é un ristorante molto famoso qui a
mosca
guardate che vista tutto addobbato per
natale si vede tutta la città
stiamo per iniziare a mangiare e ci
stanno facendo fare queste cosa
praticamente ci mettono qualche goccia
di vodka nelle mani vedete mi hanno
messo la vodka nelle mani adesso
bisogna sfregare e poi annusare allora
questo è l'antipasto che é pane
tipico nero con sopra un lardo a base di cocco buono
tu ogni volta dici buono non si capisce se é perché ti sto riprendendo o cosa
spegni un attimo la telecamera non potete capire l'emozione ragazzi sono davanti al teatro
Bolshoi per tutti i ballerini, io
sono stata ballerina anni fa, è
un'emozione enorme
eccoci dentro guardate che meraviglia
allora ragazzi siamo nella famosissima
piazza rossa fa freddino quando
siamo arrivati dicevamo che non faceva
freddo ma era ieri oggi è diverso
pure le campane
questa sera a cena da puskin che é un
famosissimo ristorante di mosca
dove ovviamente cucinano piatti tipici
assaggeremo questi piatti io ho un pó paura il pane é molto buono
secondo giorno ieri comunque eravamo
molto coperti ma abbiamo sentito un po
di freddo quindi oggi ci siamo coperti
ancora di più io ho tipo sei maglie addosso
e ho aggiunto il colbacco oggi dovremmo
girare un pó la città quindi staremo
e quindi dovevamo per forza
coprirci ostriche e champagne viene giù
una valanga striscio lo skipass
settimana bianca allora ricapitoliamo un
attimo quanti strati abbiamo addosso io
ho tre pantacollant un collant di lana un pantacollant termico
e un pantacollant con il pail dentro poi sopra ho un body di
cashmere sopra la maglietta termica
sopra ancora un collo alto abbastanza
sottile e  sopra ancora un maglione bello
spesso e poi la giacca oggi siamo
venuti a visitare la gelateria piú alta del
mondo
e ci troviamo all'89 piano
allora la situazione è questa
freddo salvatore sembra un unno uscito
da mulan te lo ricordi salvo
oggi abbiamo pranzato qui si chiama depo ed é un
come fosse un centro commerciale con al posto dei negozi tutti dei vari
ristorantini e bar ognuno con delle
specialità diverse
visitiamo il museo aerospaziale e
dell'aviazione di mosca le ragazze
quando hanno freddo uguali io io quando
esco d'inverno stessa faccia
stasera siamo al ristorante ottuple è
molto carino e si mangia pure molto
bene questo è purè di patate
scusate l'ho mangiato quindi non è
bellissimo da vedere però é purè di patate con una sorta di spezzatino e queste
sembrano delle chips delle patatine molto buono salvo invece cosa hai
già finito non ho fatto in tempo ad accendere la videocamera ragazzi ultimo giorno
purtroppo terzo giorno oggi facciamo una
visita al museo puskin e
e niente sono bionda
sono biondissima adoro
ragazzi stiamo per iniziare una lezione
di cucina pronti carichi
allora dobbiamo preparare i blini che
sono le crepe russe tipiche quindi zucchero farina e uova
in siciliano si dice un poco arripizzata
allora situazione attuale nel bel mezzo
dello spadellamento di una crepe mi sono
bruciata
quindi ho smesso di fare le robe però
ha continuato salvo per me adesso abbiamo appena finito di mangiare tutte le crepe e
abbiamo fatto anche dei ravioli con
dentro carne cipolla aglio
non so se me la sento...
dopo una lezione di cucina siamo volati
in aeroporto si torna a casa sono stati
pochi giorni ma molto intensi speriamo
tantissimo che vi sia piaciuto questo
vlog
e vi metterò magari in descrizione tutti
posti che abbiamo visitato e i ristoranti
dove siamo stati così se vi capiterà mai
di venire qui troverete tutte le
informazioni se volete saperne di più seguite visit moscow vi lascio qua il nome del
profilo con tutti insomma altri
consigli su mosca da mosca é tutto un
saluto linea allo studio ADOROOOO